are you not telling me the futures
changed if I saw Chabot our murder you
we need to figure out everything that
happens leading up the iris is death if
we can change one of these events we can
change them all all right I swear I'll
protect iris needs a hero right now I we
can prove that we can alter the future
here and now writing mcfly not survive
you back to the future
three
hey youtubers is Charlie happy holidays
new flash footage let's break it down
future flash causing all kinds of
problems there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway going on now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be
sure to click that Bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss out on anything so
what's going on in this is that they're
basically trying to go back to that
moment that they saw iris West killed
but Wally is going along this time and
they're gonna try and stops avatar
two-on-one maybe they can finally defeat
him but the problem with that is if
you've learned anything from previous
seasons on the flash is that when you
try to change the future time finds a
way of replacing that thing that you
were trying to stop with something
that's even worse or equally as bad
didn't you you're experiencing temporal
reversion yeah how long a day and some
change it's like I'm living it all over
yet yeah oh that's good I mean there's
not too much you could have messed up
yet how did this happen I don't know I
mean I was running faster than I've ever
ran and the first time that I visited
some really horrible things happen there
was a tidal wave they'll not tell me I
do not want to know anything I've had
the future you experience nothing
looking but dr. wells I Barry time is an
extremely fragile construct any
deviation no matter how small could
result in a cataclysm now here's what
you're going to do everything you did
before
every word you uttered every step you
took you're going to do again and you're
not going to tell anyone this happened
so even if they were able to stops
avatar in the future from killing iris
west somebody else would probably end up
dying
like maybe Wally would end up dying so
you're really just trading iris for
somebody else on team flash
you also see Caitlin snows killer frost
eye so it seems like she's getting worse
and worse she took those bracelets off
during Christmas like oh hey let's make
it snow this will be nice but every time
she uses her powers she becomes a little
bit more of that killer frost persona
the other big thing not quite so dire
iris and Barry in bed together just
getting it on so they're finally doing
all the things and it looks like based
on irises reaction he finally comes
clean but one of the big problems that
he's had this past season is in keeping
secrets like the
of this magnitude from his friends
usually that winds up hurting them more
than it helps like the big lesson of
flashpoint is that Barry is not allowed
to change time it just doesn't work that
way he winds up making things worse when
he tries to change events that was what
Jay Garrick's coffeeCup explainer was
all about so let me show you something
you know what your mommy kid this coffee
cup right here think of it as the
space-time continuum where if you go
back in time it breaks not real I mean
you could reset the timeline you can try
to fix it but no matter how hard you try
there's no don't be exactly how it was
so really the wrong lesson that Barry
has learned is that he can't go back
into the past to try and change the
future but the whole twist of this clip
is that he tries to vibe into the future
to change the future
so he's like oh this is totally
different see I'm going into the future
I'm not going into the past they're also
back in the Time Vault here I know a lot
of people were wondering about that in
season 2 what happened to Gideon Gideon
is sort of like an all-encompassing AI
kind of like Siri that is now on the
legends of tomorrow ship the Waverider
so I think that's the only reason that
they're not using it on the flash just
because they don't want to do that on
every single show all the time so they
still have access to the technology that
gives them this future newspaper but it
seems kind of limited like they could
look at the newspaper and as they make
changes they can see how the newspaper
changes so the way they're setting this
up in the back half of the season is
that Barry is going to do anything to
save iris which usually has a negative
connotation like he is going to cross
the line the line that Jay Garrick
spelled out for him pretty clearly don't
change time dude it only makes things
worse so he's probably gonna cross that
line and it's gonna lead to the future
flash message that we heard on legends
of tomorrow a war is coming captain
and it's someone you're gonna be called
back to Central City to fight it so you
need to know that while you and your
team have been in the temporal zone I
made a choice that affected the timeline
as you know whenever you alter the past
those changes affect the president get
compounded in the future when you return
you will be in the new timeline I
created where everyone's past and
everyone's future has been affected
including yours when you come back don't
trust anything or anyone not even me
you may have also noticed Harrison Wells
here looks way more hardcore that's
probably because you know crazy hair
here this is earth to Harrison wells
because earth 19 Harrison wells HR just
does not seem this focused he's usually
dancing around wearing weird scars
wearing glasses making jokes getting
people coffee
earth - Harrison wells the hard core
Harrison wells is way less talkative and
wears way more plain clothes so this
would seem to imply the Jessie quick
earth - Harrison wells have come back
[Music]
right yeah okay let's do this over one
morning while I'm gone never ever no
matter what oh oh well what was he gonna
say we're all like why was he gonna say
that's cool though I'm starving
so they don't really confirm them
anywhere in the trailer but just based
on the way Harrison wells looks in this
clip it just seems like it's earth to
Harrison wells
we also see Wally and Barry versus
plunder there was that other trailer
that I posted where it's like right
after this moment after they've taken
into prison so this fills in a lot of
gaps so plunder is sort of like the
villain of the week even though he ties
in with the serialized Savatage
storyline so remember when Barry went
three months into the future that's
basically when this Irish moment is
happening they had the newscast with
plunder being put on trial
in other legal news the highly
publicized trial of Jared Murillo aka
thunder comes to a close
Marilla was found guilty of grand theft
and aggravated assault after he was
caught by the flash robbing the Central
City Museum earlier this year so
whatever it is he does it seems like he
has some interesting role to play in
Barry changing irises fate but plunder
himself has this really hardcore gun so
it looks like he's trying to pull a hit
on someone maybe the flash himself but
it'll be interesting to see who he goes
after the killer frost teaser is a
little more straightforward like Caitlin
just slowly being forced to use her
powers to help her friends but as a
consequence of that she slowly becomes
more in more killer frost more and more
evil turning against the group so
ironically the thing that she called him
out for or killer frost called him out
for messing with their lives he is
continuing to do in this clip but I
think the way they're setting it up is
just to make him feel more sympathetic
because we're trying to save irises life
so you have the whole team working here
you have Cisco who's agreeing to vibe
him into the future even though it's
probably and terribly so they're messing
with everyone's lives but it seems like
there's more consent from the rest of
the group it's not just Barry acting by
himself anymore but you can let me know
what do you think is going to happen
when they try and change the future
again clearly it's not going to work but
what do you think the consequence is
going to be like this avatar kills
someone else is this a self-fulfilling
prophecy whereby the steps they take to
try and avoid this future is what ends
up causing it to happen in the first
place that's one of the big mine trips
of the flash is that through time travel
his life is kind of like this loop like
when he eventually dies and you know
whatever final season in our future
battle he ends up becoming the bolt of
lightning that gave him powers sort of
restarting the timeline so even though I
think the flash is going to run for a
lot of seasons we might get teasers for
that too I'm hoping they do that
storyline at some point where flash
becomes the bolt of lightning that
originally gave himself powers I was
originally doing a video about future
flash when this footage drop so what
will happen is in a couple days I'll
just finish that and post it so I'll
explain that future Barry message what's
going on with this dark as time
I'm buried that just doing everything he
can to try and save iris I've also got a
video for the flash prophecy which gets
into more of this killer frost stuff
like someone eventually betraying the
team someone falling from grace someone
dying so there are any other flash bonus
videos you guys want me to do during the
break just let me know in the comments
below
giveaway time congratulations to this
week's winner Freddy tremble you win a
flash ring please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there is a new
round that started in this video I'll
name the winner the next time I post a
DC video but what's going to happen
later tonight is I have some new Rick
and Morty season 3 footage so I'll post
that they'll also be a giveaway for that
there's like a really cool Rick and
Morty hardcover that they're releasing
so I'll be giving that away so look out
for that in a couple hours well you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
for that other flash trailer and you can
click here for my breakdown of the
Justice League teaser they just dropped
trailer coming really soon thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
Oh